all right Gigi I know you are a huge fan
of RuPaul's Drag Race am i we're
probably could probably have a battle of
whose Nagar fan I feel like you're the
bigger fan but I'm like right up there
with you I want to know who is GG
rooting for on season 11 alright well
there's two categories I'm those I'm
rooting for and those that I'm in love
with oh okay so I'm in love wet smoky
ganache you love silky
yeah she's a little cringe-worthy
sometimes but a lot of times Sally so
honestly she's just living her life and
I love that kind of energy where it's
just so over the top she really does
make me laugh like I like actually lol
when I watch her funny but sometimes it
just needs to be turned down just yeah
but like you can't change the she's
gonna do what she wants to do clearly
those I'm rooting for plastique of
course I think is flawless and last week
she kind of changed up her look and I
felt like that was a huge like departure
from her Barbie aesthetic and I saw a
different side to her so I was like oh
alright I'm rooting for you even more
now because before I was just like okay
she's like the most beautiful drag queen
ever gorgeous of course Brooklyn Heights
phillipians she's gonna be here for
pride right yeah who are you rooting for
I'm rooting for Brooklyn Heights I love
Brooklyn Heights
I like Evy because I do like I like drag
that always isn't just pretty you know
what I mean totally he really can do
pull we've just seen on the show she
gave glamour she gave that lammer
and she can do the odd stuff which is
fantastic
oddly avi isn't in the bottom what are
you gonna go on RuPaul's Drag Race as a
judge I mean I literally that's one of
my that's one of my bucket list thank
you well but I was on it in in spirit
when Farrah did me for snatch game so
while I was technically there oh my god
technically I forgot yeah so I'm like
okay if I can be a judge I can be a
judge that's fab but I was technically
you were but we put it out to the
universe that you are gonna be a judge
season 12 of RuPaul's Drag yes
you know what I would love like you know
Lady Gaga came in in the workroom and
like acted as if she was one of the
computers I would love to go in as me
yeah and be like oh yeah like I'm
competing yeah like they let me in and
like to see what people say like she's
serious I'm gonna be like kidding that
would be fun